The athletes of today are not only much better than those of the past,...
...they also look incredibly different.
The weird thing is, scientists note...
...that the human body hasn't evolved that dramatically in the past 100 years.
So why do Olympic athletes look so different now...
...compared to the first Winter Olympics in 1924?
In the early 1900s, the ideal athlete was based on classical human proportions.
If we imagine body types distributed as a bell curve...
...with extreme body types being on the far ends,...
...it was the middle of the curve that was considered the best physical build.
Athletes who are not too tall but not too short, not too bulky but not too skinny,...
...and well, average were deemed as ideal for the Olympic pursuit.
But this has all changed.
Now athletes succeed based on their highly specialized body types,...
...which allow them to excel in a world of growing competitiveness.
For example, athletes who are required to spin in the air,...
...such as figure skaters or gymnasts, have been getting smaller.
These athletes with short specialized body types have an advantage over average or tall athletes,...
...weeding them out at the elite level.
In fact in 30 years, the average professional gymnast has shrunk from 5'3" to 4'9".